my colleague from the nfl media group
ian rapport back here on the rich eisen
show how are you sir
what's going on man how are you i'm
doing fine i'm looking at the calendar i
see june 1st which means just
help me with this this is your you know
part of your news and information
uh that means tomorrow's the first
post-june first day correct
right yeah uh well i mean yes and no
not saying you're wrong but today is
actually the first post june one day but
after four o'clock
after four o'clock so four o'clock today
is when the clock starts officially
uh on june 2nd on the nfl calendar
yeah correct right which is basically
like wishing someone happy birthday at
like twelve or one a.m
i get it but like also don't call wake
me up i'm sleeping i understood
i get it so so it's not saying that my
parents did that for years before i said
anything but i'm just
saying that well those crazy rap reports
um so you know something could obviously
be done and then say we'll announce it
at a certain time right now so
i guess it doesn't it's not like we're
waiting staring at the clock
for the pot to boil over what's
happening with julio jones as you and i
are talking
right now yeah i mean this is always
kind of the weird thing because like it
is a deadline
and because there's nothing else going
on besides my terrible golf game
it is what everyone is talking about but
it's not
actually a deadline it's more of like
the it's more of a deadline like when
the franchise tag window open
opens up like in february right like we
all talk about it but you don't get to
find out who actually gets tagged to
like
march 14th or whatever it was this year
right um
it's more like that like it opens up the
door now
the falcons could have traded him before
the draft and to say we'll process it
you know june 2nd much like the rams and
lions did their quarterback trade
on a saturday night at 10 30 in uh
february when was that february oh yeah
oh yeah in february
um and then we're like oh cool it'll be
official in three weeks everyone get
ready for that so they could do that
um the weird thing about julio is and
you know it is
it's possible it gets done this week but
there's no
actual deadline until training camp
right so if the falcons are like we have
to get a first round pick
we are not trading them unless we get
that they may not trade them until
you know july 27th or something like
that like
you know i would be a little surprised
if something is not done
before training camp but other than that
it's really just whatever deadline
they decide to create like they could
tell teams like we have to get it done
this week so put your best offer and
then we are trading him i haven't heard
that happen otherwise like it's all kind
of waiting around to see if
something spurs movement in a trade
market that seems
pretty fleshed out and i don't get the
sense is really accelerated anywhere
well then let's go in search of an
earlier deadline
uh the the concept that they need to
create the cap space to in fact pay
their rookies do they need to actually
get these guys under contract before a
mandatory
mini camp this month or the fact that
they've already been on the field
because
you know uh because they were you know
at a rookie camp i mean is there
is there a time by which they have to
get these rookies signed and under
contract
and uh it's really by training camp
that's a good question because
you know every year
you know rookies sort of sign at
different times right like the rams do a
thing where they have everyone go
through
uh you know otas and rookie camp and
mini camp and then they all sign it once
after
some financial education but that's a
lot of times like in june
but sometimes we see draft picks don't
sign until right before training camp
and that happens every year too
so the falcons do need the room um
i think they would like to get something
done
for business purposes but they actually
don't have to so they could
have everything fine in their offseason
of all the rookies show up everything be
good rookies will sign waivers as they
do
and then sign everyone right before
training camp and just say our problem
you know
we'll be it will be against the clock
but we'll have to hustle to get it done
but because rookie deals are generally
so easy like they probably will be able
to get it done
even if it's a mad scramble like a day
before training camp huh
so uh ian rappaport here on the rich
eisen show my colleague from the nfl
media group
um who's in on julio who's in on julio
and who do you think
who do you think's already put that one
on the table if you believe that if you
believe that is
in fact the case you think so what do
you got for me
well to me if there was a clean one on
the table
for next year they probably would have
already taken it would be my guess
okay um you know because they that's
that's what they've told teams they've
wanted they want to won
if they get a one i think they would
have taken it so to me
if if there is a one on the table it's
probably not
a one for this year and you know like
sort of the way teams think about it
like let's say you know i want to won
for this year and you want to give me a
one
from 2023 right
well that basically value-wise is
considered a two
if you want to give me a first round
pick for three years out that's
considered a three
so they may have a one on the table but
i just don't know that it's this year
but like you know there was some
discussion i think from colleague mike
airfollow
that the rams were involved the rams
could give a first round pick but it's
not going to be for
i think 2035 is their next one i should
be incorrect on that yes my
my son who's about to be bar mitzvahed
is going to get uh
go through graduate school when uh the
next time they actually exactly um and
that's what they
they could give that but that's and
that's valuable but it's not
a one like we talk about a one i love
the rams being involved
god they're so aggressive they really
just like screw it let's go we got a
window let's roll
that would be amazing if that actually
happens because my gosh
what a game changer that would be for
stafford to get who
i mean that i can't even go down that
road so interesting
and everybody would lose their minds
because they go there goes the rams
again
going all in but you know theoretically
they could go all in every year
and then just trade the draft picks for
the next year because every year you get
new draft picks
that's true so okay so um
who else is in who are you hearing is in
patriots one right or
one of them who else is who else would
actually be in and and
um and you're saying the rams being
involved doesn't mean like the
you only look for people who have the
cap room that could absorb that 15
million in change on the spot right so
who's in
well you can always sort of create space
but um i mean i would say you know the
titans are a team that's been discussed
49ers i know gareth all mentioned rams
we talked about
patriots you know i i'm sure that
they're gonna look into it
not sure would totally make sense for me
um
just because you know the value wouldn't
be great and bill still very much cares
about value like
to me you know they spent a lot in
parades and everybody went crazy
how is that possible they probably ended
up getting some good deals on
some free agents you know like 12
million dollars for the top
free agent tight end when it probably
should be 14
that's actually a good deal value-wise
like the patriots care about value
them being involved in julio makes sense
that they would call but i'm not sure
they are going to get it
you know the ravens have had some
interest but i don't think it's going to
be a one there and that salary gives
them some problems so
um those are sort of the teams that have
been
potentially in the mix you know the
titans do seem to make the most sense
um i just don't know that that has moved
i don't know that
it doesn't sound like their
conversations have been overly recent
the titans
and the falcons ian wrap report here on
the rich eisen show
and uh what what's the what's the
current status of
aaron rodgers in the packers now that
we're we're post june 1
later on today and something is
potentially more likely than it would
have been just yesterday
even though it seems like uh the packers
are have no intention of
of moving this guy so what do you got
for me yeah on that i would agree
no no intention of moving him i haven't
checked the instagram account of
the actress whose name i forget that
he's vacationing with yes
it's miles teller's wife is what you're
referring to right yeah
okay so i had not i don't i don't know
what i'm sure she's very good i just
don't know what show she's i had not
heard of her before she started posting
about aaron rodgers
um because i haven't checked her
instagram account recently to know if
he's still in hawaii
um i don't get the sense that much has
changed at all and that's another one
where like
there's not much incentive to do
anything right now like yes the packers
and you know they've been trying to get
a deal done i know they would really
really really like to get a
an extension done that makes him happy
to kind of end this issue
i just don't know that anything happens
soon like is you know the deadline for
mandatory mini camp is that a real
deadline like i don't know
let me let me pause you right there then
okay let's let's stop right there
so you know the packers want him to sign
a contract that will make him happy
correct
that's what you're saying so then why
wouldn't aaron rodgers want to sign a
contract
that would make him happy is it simply
because that contract should have been
offered to him
the minute they lost the nfc
championship game and he was wondering
about his future
and it did not come because of whatever
reasoning that caused him
to um feel the way that he
that has been reported for him to feel
and that he confirmed with kenny mayne
uh one week ago last night i mean
is that what is this that that he wanted
it when he wanted it and it didn't come
and he's pissed and he's now going to
make him wait is that basically a way to
look at this
right now what i sort of i sort of think
about like i do with a lot of contract
negotiations and you know this is not
the first negotiation to get
personal and heated i would say sideways
um
i don't know that he hasn't i don't know
that he's not signing it i just know
that he hasn't agreed to it yet like
maybe they haven't
done a deal that's good enough you know
like i mean that's
i see this all as a you know there's
there's plenty of other parts of it but
i see it in part as a negotiation
so the fact that he hasn't accepted a
deal just means the offer isn't good
enough yet
or he's not ready to accept what is what
is their current offer
you know so they they can make this work
financially they can make this work
contractually they can make it so he has
enough guaranteed money
so he's not worried about jordan loves
supplanting him ever
so he can retire on his own terms i mean
these are the sorts of things he wants i
just
i just don't know that they're there yet
and that was interesting to me in the
kenny main interview
was he didn't close the door on anything
no i mean
he kicked the can down the road the way
that i termed it as he turned up the
heat on gouda kuns like he
he is i don't think that this uh goose
if you will of
being good queens is remotely cooked
enough for rogers i mean
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna get
that goose cooked even more
when he's out there golfing with the
scientist as tom brady's instagram
account referred to
bryson de chambeau it's gonna be great i
mean july 6th is going to be a date
where
you know brady and phil will get in
aaron's face and have fun and
with his situation and he'll make a
couple comments that'll be caught on a
hot mic that works because
i mean that that's just gonna turn that
thing up to spinal tap 11 as far as i'm
concerned because that's going to be
right
a couple weeks before training camp hits
and we're going to wonder if he's going
to show up
so that's my question for you is if
green if if you're wondering if the
terms are not well uh uh
um you know to rogers satisfaction
then green bay desire to get him signed
long term
or to a contract that makes him
satisfied
you know the only way that that does
that is to
make jordan love inoperable as his
successor in the first year
first iteration of his professional
contract basically
blowing up the clock in the manner that
he said he threw a wrench into it
with an mvp season you know i think that
this is the rational conversation to be
had right now is to try and read some
tea leaves here
ian i mean i don't think that's i don't
think any of that is wrong
um because that's sort of i think what
he wants
and look roger's bullet that uh just
sort of
time situation anyway yeah kind of like
tom brady did like i'm sure the patriots
would have loved to have a succession
plan of tom brady jimmy garoppolo
sorry brady screwed all that up um and
roger screwed it up too
because he probably had his best season
you know maybe except for the super bowl
yeah he was
he was awesome last year and the
previous year he had not been as good
and he was like yeah maybe you don't and
now they have to recalibrate which to me
is all
okay but again like you gotta you know
if you're the packers and you want this
thing done
like you got to prove it contractually
probably like you said making sure that
jordan love is not an issue for rogers
moving forward
through his current contract or
something like that so
um okay so we're basically playing a
waiting game right here to see
how that all plays out and training camp
would be
one uh flash point the next one would be
the mandatory mini camp in a couple
weeks to see if he shows up
right and at some point jordan love is
going to have to talk
i imagine the packers went through their
mini camp last week without
putting him out there at some point he
is going to you know
put in his two cents and he's the future
i mean there's no doubt about it yeah
and
the weirdest thing for the packers is
jordan love is by all accounts a great
guy
right like i hear him and rogers have a
really good relationship and everybody
likes i have no idea what he can do on
the football field but seems to be a
really good
person upstanding human who probably is
gonna
handle this extremely well uh
just we haven't heard from him yet we
heard rogers a couple of times
plus singing we don't even know i don't
even know if
jordan loves what lyrics to taylor swift
songs
dude that's the second reference you've
made to that now i mean
you know look we get our information
where we get our information okay
what information are you gleaning from
that what are you what are you agreeing
what information you gleaning from that
he's just living his best
life and he's making it like you know he
always had to play the guitar did you
know that aaron rodgers knew how to play
the guitar
i didn't i did not and that was pre-june
1st so
you know it'll be more costly uh thanks
for the call ian i greatly appreciate it
i always enjoy richard all right right
back at you there's ian wrap aboard
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here